all the heat from the Red Dwarf plus its
strong gravity would make Jupiter grow
in size the gas giants atmosphere would
puff up as all the gases were heating up
and expanding some of Jupiter's
atmosphere would start to escape into
space and toward the Stellar Intruder
eventually all the runaway Jupiter gases
would form a hot ring around eblm Jo
55557 AB the red dwarf star would keep
slowly ripping Jupiter apart now it
would be eating whole chunks of our gas
giant for a moment Jupiter would take
the shape of an American football but
soon enough the star would engulf it
entirely sorry Jupiter you didn't stand
a chance